says loneliness is a kind of tax we have
to pay to atone for a certain complexity
of mind
that's true that's true that's not bad
for allah um
uh yeah it's true um
but that's laid on top of or there's a
magnifying effect or a multiplier here
which is
the complexity of mind plus the decision
of whether or not to deploy this into
the real world
well again that depends on whether or
not your first forays
were received warmly or not
seth godin had this amazing insight
where he said uh a lot of the time we
need support but only the first time
around
that when you start to get some positive
reinforcement over time you can be you
can become more bone-headed you can
become more uh
singularly driven yes
but the first time can be
more
difficult to get through and i think
that's true
a more troubling one in a way is the one
that the older you get i'm now in my 40s
i'm 42 now but
um i was speaking musician friend the
other day who just
one of his
um
seniors that just died and
uh i know what was on my mind was on his
which is is
the fact that as you as you get older in
your
profession your career you you notice
the people who you looked to you
obviously thought were always going to
be there go
um
and then of course you have the
inevitable thing of
oh hell that's gonna have to be
the position that's filled by
people of my generation
and um there's a responsibility that
comes from that there's also um
there's also
when you're starting off
hopefully you will have i certainly had
uh great mentors and
people i sought out
really
they didn't just get given to me i
sought them out to
help me start off
and
of course they die off
but then
they don't entirely because
that which got you started
is is is you become carries forward
within you yeah and
and so
it is a sort of eternal process of
it's what tom stoppard in arcadia
describes he says at one point something
like he says you know
the character um this is the the student
says um says to tutor something like she
says how can you cope with the fact that
all these players were lost in the
library at alexandria you know this
number by uh aesculus this number by
that how can you cope with all these
things that were lost and he says
because nothing is lost
nothing is lost to the march
he says the plays that were lost will
come back in fragments or
return again in another language
uh
we shed as we pick up
nothing's lost to the march but all we
have is the march
it's a constant process of loss and
renewal and discovery and loss and
rediscovery again
and
almost every profession i would have
thought is like that
being a writer is particularly like that
because you see the people who started
you off as they start to fall away
you have
and keep certain things they gave you
and there are for me at any rate
there are connections i feel to people
who i never met
through people i did know
and now
i feel quite often
uh
walking through a library or in a
bookshop or something
i feel like almost the whole place is
surrounded by friends somehow you know
oh i i think i knew him sometimes it is
something i know but
more often i give a connection to that
person
and
so the whole thing is a sort of
is a
is like a
a constant
rediscovery that's what that's what t.s
eliot saw it as
it's like
i'm sorry i sound like i'm waffling but
i'm coming to a major point i promise
um a version of uh
history and ideas that
is um
common at the moment which is endless
progress
and i never really believed in that just
innately i didn't think that things were
always getting better i always thought
it was all up for grabs i don't know why
i've always thought that but i did
even the people who believed in the sort
of fukiyama stuff
you had to have
but
about two world wars
those are two quite big footnotes you
know to a theory
but the theory of progress is
most people including people i meet
grown-ups all the time who believe in it
everything's always just getting better
inevitably
um and they think that art and other
things goes along an inevitable path
getting better and better bigger and
bigger clearer and clearer
more and more accomplished but there's
another way of seeing things which is
the one i've just been trying to outline
which is
that it's actually cyclical the whole
thing
that things
are lost and come around again
and that's that's the case with ideas
for sure
i mean
our libraries
die every day in the heads of people
and
they will hopefully be reborn in another
head
the same day
um
goethe says somewhere um
in one of his poems about the
the need to recreate that which has been
created
um
and i think that's one of the great
noble enterprises which is to recreate
that which has been created
to rediscover that which has been
as elite put it lost and found and lost
again and again
and everything's like that
all the time wisdom is being lost
but hopefully it's being picked up again
by someone else
you know every time you lose you lose
somebody irreplaceable
and they're not replaced but somebody
else steps in
and
that's the march
what's happening people if you enjoyed
that then press here for the full
unedited episode
and don't forget to subscribe
peace